Suecia fue el primer país en reconocer
la identidad trans en 1972 pero desde el
año pasado está reduciendo el acceso de
menores a tratamientos hormonales de
reasignación de sexo en 2022 fueron
suspendidos salvo raras excepciones y
ahora acaban de restringir drásticamente
el uso de la extirpación mamaria en
adolescentes teníamos un protocolo
diseñado para casos muy raros y extremos
y de repente la demanda se disparó Así
que seguimos utilizando ese protocolo
desde 2008 la disforia de género creció
un 1500% entre jóvenes nacidas como
mujeres de 13 A 17 años Carolina jamski
ha seguido de cerca el tema
La recomendación de la junta Nacional de
salud y bienestar es esperar a dar el
tratamiento para que tengan su pubertad
y luego ver qué pasa esto se debe a
investigaciones que señalan que
alrededor del 70 u 80 por ciento de
personas que se identifican con el
género opuesto después de la pubertad se
vuelven a identificar con el género de
nacimiento
sin embargo jóvenes trans como Antonia
Line Hall están molestas con la decisión
y lo consideran una vulneración de sus
derechos
es muy difícil de explicar si no has
pasado por la transición
creo que las hormonas salvan a mucha
gente y me molesta que sí quisiera
realizar la transición con 13 años ahora
mismo no tendría ninguna posibilidad
Elías es activista por los derechos lgbt
considera que una disforia de género
maltratada puede llevar al suicidio
sabemos que el único tratamiento eficaz
para la disforia de género es la
atención a la afirmación de género de
acuerdo con las necesidades de cada
paciente según lo decidido con su
cuidador
esta problemática se ha convertido en un
tema político no solo en Suecia con
múltiples países europeos evaluando los
tratamientos trans en adolescentes